we begin this morning with a one man's
apparent suicide mission that caused
tension in skies over Seattle for more
than an hour Friday night authorities
say an employee of horizon air a
regional carrier owned by Alaska
Airlines stole an empty turboprop plane
from Seattle Tacoma International
Airport before crashing it on Ketron
island in Puget Sound southwest of
Seattle
amateur video shows the plane being
followed by f-15 fighter jets before the
crash CBS News Transportation
correspondent Kris Van Cleave is in our
Washington bureau with the latest Kris
good morning good morning the FBI says
this does not appear to be an act of
terror instead authorities say the 29
year old Horizon Air Ground Service
agent was suicidal when he stole the
plane it was not in service it was
parked in a maintenance area last night
investigators believe the crash occurred
because the man who appeared to lack
flying skills was trying to do stunts
cell phone video captured the moment the
stolen twin-engine horizon airlines
plane does what appears to be a mid-air
barrel roll before dropping down
perilously above the water line off the
coast of Seattle Washington
how is this guy doing passenger plane
just goes sideways goes almost like
perpendicular to the ground and just
flies I don't like felt like a few
hundred feet above the ground in radio
communications air traffic controllers
and a horizon pilot refer to the man
flying as rich as they talked with him
and became increasingly clear the
airline employee was not going to safely
land the plane I've got a lot of people
that care about me and
it's going to disappoint them since to
you that I did this
just a broken guy got a few screws loose
I guess a pair of f-15 fighter jets were
scrambled from a base in Portland Oregon
and intercepted the q400 turboprop
within minutes they could be seen from
the ground trailing the stolen plane one
was low near the plane and one was high
way up in the air and they followed it
around and a few minutes later we heard
a loud explosion noise the hour-long
flight ended in a fiery crash on contra
Island a small island with few residents
investigators don't believe anyone on
the ground was hurt and the fire does
not pose a threat to anyone it does not
appear the man who stole the plane
survived the crash apparently it was
somebody who did something wrong did
something foolish and may well have paid
with his life the man has not yet been
identified as spokesman for NORAD the
North American Aerospace Defense Command
says the fighter jets did not fire on
the stolen plane flights out of SeaTac
Airport were temporarily grounded after
the unauthorized takeoff
the FBI will lead the investigation for
now Tony
Kris you mentioned the plane was in a
maintenance position at the time it took
off how was this individual able to get
control of the plane and then get it on
a runway well we know he worked on the
ground for horizon so it would not be
uncommon particularly if he worked in
the maintenance department for him to
know how to power on the airplane and
and some basic pre-flight procedures you
would do to get the plane going if
you've got knowledge of how the throttle
works and basic controls of the plane
you certainly would be capable of
taxiing it out to a runway throttling it
up and taking off landing is is a lot
trickier of course all right Kris Van
Cleave Forest in Washington Chris thank
you